what I want to do in this video is think
about how expressions are formed and
then words we use to describe the
different parts of an expression and the
reason why this is useful is when you
hear other people refer to some
expression and say oh I don't agree with
the second term or the third term has
four factors or why is the coefficient
on that term six you'll know what
they're talking about and you can
communicate in the same way so let's
think about what those words actually
mean so we have an expression here the
first thing I want to think about are
the terms the terms of an expression or
what a term is and one way to think
about it is a term a term of an
expression are the things or the terms
are the things that are getting added
and subtracted so for example in this
expression right over here you have
three things that are getting added and
subtracted the first thing you're taking
2 times 3 you're adding that to 4 and
then from that you're subtracting 7y so
in this example you have 3 you have 3
terms the first term is 2 times 3 the
second term is just the number 4 and the
third term is the number or as is e is 7
times y now let's think about the term
factor and when people are talking about
a factor especially in terms of an
expression they're talking about the
things that are getting multiplied in
each term so for example if you said
what are the factors of the first term
the first term refers to this one right
over here 2 times 3 and there's two
factors there's a 2 and a 3 and they are
being multiplied by each other so here
you have two factors in the first term
what about the second term the second
term right over here the second this was
the first term the second term here has
only one factor just the four it's not
being multiplied by anything and the
third term here once again has two
factors it's the product of 7 times y so
we have two factors here we have a 7 and
a y and this constant factor here this
number 7 that is multiplying the
variable also has a special name it is
called the coefficient of this term
coefficient coefficient
coefficient and the coefficient is the
non variable that multiplies the rest of
the term that's one way of thinking
about it so here's 7y even if with seven
XY or seven and XYZ or seven X Y Z
squared that non variable that's
multiplying everything else we would
consider to be the coefficient now let's
do a few more examples and in each of
these I encourage you actually right now
to pause the video think about what the
terms are how many terms are there in
the in each expression how many factors
in each term and what are the
coefficients so let's look at this first
one it's clear that we have three things
being added together this is the first
term this is the second term and this is
the third term so this is the first term
the second term this is the third term
and they each have two factors this
first one has the factors 3 and X the
second one here has the factors x and y
and this third one is has the factors Y
& Z now what are the coefficients here
will remember coefficients is a non
variable multiplying a bunch of other
variables and so here the coefficient in
this first term right over here is a 3
now you might be saying well what about
the coefficients on these terms right
over here depending on how you think
about it one way to say is well X Y is
the same thing as 1 times X Y so some
people would say that hey you have a
coefficient of 1 here on the XY or it's
implicitly there that it wasn't written
but you're multiplying everything by 1
and that might be subject to a little
bit of interpretation one way or another
now this one is really interesting
because if we look at the bigger
expression if we look at the whole thing
if we look at the whole thing it's
clearly made up of three terms the first
term is X Y Z the second term is X +1
that thing whole thing times y and then
the third term is 4x and if you look at
that level if you look at the first term
and you say well how many factors does
that have well you would say that it has
three factors x y&z how many factors
does the second term have well you could
say well it has two factors one factor
is X plus y and then the other factor is
why it's multiplying x + or sorry the
first factor is x + 1 and the second one
is why it's multiplying this expression
this expression itself
the smaller expression itself is one of
the factors and the other one is why and
then this third one also has two factors
a 4 and an X and if someone said here
what's the coefficient on this term you
say hey look the coefficient the
coefficient is the 4 now let's look at
this one over here actually before I
look at that one what was interesting
about this is that here you had a little
smaller expression itself acting as one
of the factors so then you can go and
then zoom in on this expression right
over here and you can ask the same
question on this smaller expression how
many terms does it have well it has two
terms an X and a 1 those are the two
things being added or subtracted and
each of them have exactly one factor so
when we're giving these there's you can
keep nesting these expressions to think
about when you talk about terms or
factors or factors of terms you have to
really specify what what part of the
nesting you're thinking about if you're
talking about the terms of this whole
expression there's 1 2 3 but then if you
go you could look at this sub expression
which itself is a factor of a term and
say oh well there's only two terms in
this one now let's look at this one how
many how many terms
well once again there's clearly three
actually let me add one more cuz I'm
tired of expressions with three terms so
I'm just going to add a one year so now
we clearly have four terms this is the
first term second term third term fourth
term and how many factors are in each of
them well this is interesting you might
say well a lot of the factors are the
things that are being multiplied but
here I'm dividing by Y remember dividing
by Y is the same thing as multiplying by
its reciprocal so it would usually be
considered to have three factors here
where the factors are 3x + 1 / y if you
multiply 3 times x times 1 over Y you're
going to get exactly what you have right
over here so you would say this has
three factors if someone asks what's the
coefficient here well you'd say well
that 3 is the coefficient here how many
factors do you have and this is a little
bit tricky because you might say well
isn't 5x squared times y isn't that
equal to 5 times x times X times y and
you'd be right and you'd be this would
be very tempting to say that you have
four factors
but the convention the what the
tradition that most people use is that
they consider the exponent of with X as
a base as just one factor as this is
just one factor so traditionally people
will say this has three factors it has a
5x squared and a Y x squared is just
considered a factor and once again
what's the coefficient it's the five so
with that in mind how many factors here
well you have three factors here you
have an X you have a y squared and you
have a Z to the fifth and then finally
this last term it's a constant term how
many factors does it have was just one
it's just got a one sitting there it's
not being multiplied by anything